Jorge Qué otros detalles se conocen de
esta medida del gobierno Daniel Ortega
Bueno una medida sin duda sin
precedentes ocurrió desde la noche de
ayer y la madrugada de hoy estos presos
políticos considerados por la sociedad
civil fueron sacados y enviados en un
avión hasta Washington si la lista de
presos políticos es de 245 quedarían muy
pocos ya en las cárceles del país esta
decisión de Nicaragua ocurre tan solo
días después de que la justicia
sandinista inhabilitó de por vida para
ejercer cargos públicos o de elección
popular al menos a 14 personas entre
ellos cuatro sacerdotes católicos y
otros de la sociedad civil el padre
Uriel vallejos quien es párroco de la
iglesia Jesús de la Divina Misericordia
eh En el interior de Nicaragua y que
está exiliado en Costa Rica confirmó al
medio local divergentes que entre los
presos políticos expulsados habrían
sacerdotes ya juzgados y condenados en
días anteriores Se desconoce también si
en la lista figura monseñor Rolando
Álvarez obispo de matagalpa aquí en el
gobierno programó su juicio para iniciar
el próximo 15 de Pero entre los
excarcelados se encuentran presos que se
encontraban ahí en la cárcel la modelo y
Esperanza desde hace más de dos años y
reos de conciencia que permanecían en la
cárcel el chipote bajo arresto o bajo
arresto domiciliario desde hace más de
600 días entre estos presos políticos
Valentina se encuentran siete personas
que pretendieron competir en las
elecciones presidenciales de noviembre
de 2021 así como líderes estudiantiles
abogados Defensores de Derechos Humanos
periodistas ex guerrilleros sandinistas
y también dirigentes de partidos
políticos de oposición en las últimas
semanas los jueces aplicaron penas
accesorias en la sentencia de condena
los precios políticos en las que les
imponían una supuesta inhabilitación
perpetua de todos sus derechos políticos
y civiles penas que para muchos expertos
en derecho penal son nulas ilegales e
inconstitucionales porque no existen en
el marco jurídico nicaragüense otros
juristas también mencionan que el
destierro o la expulsión del país solo
puede ser aplicada a extranjeros que
cometen algún delito y nunca a
nacionales pero en este caso ocurrió
todo lo contrario escuchemos el anuncio
oficial de parte del magistrado Octavio
rochura andino presidente de la sala uno
del tribunal de apelaciones de Managua
se ordenó la deportación inmediata de
222 personas sentenciadas por cometer
actos que menoscaban la independencia la
soberanía la autodeterminación del
pueblo por incitar a la violencia al
terrorismo y a la desestabilización
desestabilización económica Pero además
por lesionar los intereses supremos de
la nación establecidos en el
arrendamiento jurídico convenios y
tratados internacionales de Derechos
Humanos alterando la paz la seguridad y
el orden constitucional
los deportados fueron declarados
traidores a la patria y sancionados por
diferentes delitos graves e
inhabilitados de forma perpetua para
ejercer la función pública En nombre del
Servicio del Estado de Nicaragua así
como ejercer cargos de elección popular
quedando suspenso sus derechos
ciudadanos de forma perpetua
a esta hora los deportados ya están en
Estados Unidos de América así damos por
cumplir a la sentencia de portación era
parte del anuncio de la justicia de
nicaragüense respecto a este tema el
gobierno de Ortega Argumenta la decisión
para defender la paz y la soberanía del
país en enero pasado ya Daniel Ortega
también utilizó su primer discurso del
2023 para hablar de esto Dijo que dejó
Claro que no absolvería a los presos
políticos a pesar de las campañas por su
Liberación y aseguró que ni con cadena
perpetua podrían saldar el daño que
según él le produjeron a Nicaragua
también Valentina hace unos minutos la
asamblea nacional de Nicaragua que es
controlada por diputados oficialistas
modificó el artículo 21 de la
constitución política del país para
despojar de la nacionalidad nicaragüense
a los más de 200 presos políticos que
fueron desterrados esta madrugada Jorge
Pues nada alentador estaremos muy
pendientes de lo que pueda ocurrir en ni